the most responsible way to live is that
you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
I agree that it's important to be
playful
I think smiling is great this is our
lives this is what we spend all of our
time doing so let's embrace it and have
the best time we can rise and shine it's
an spresso time good morning belief
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you i believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that i want
to see exploded onto the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
be playful over to you Sadhguru being
playful always has been understood as a
responsibility
yes do you know right from your
childhood and to probably to your
children also you're doing if they're
just playful you think it's
irresponsible the most responsible way
to live is that you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
yes or no isn't it absolutely
irresponsible to walk around with misery
yes that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do so being playful is not
irresponsibility bling being playful is
being very responsible and responsive to
life only when you are playful you can
do that when you're serious the world
doesn't exist for you you and your
nonsense yes when you're serious it's
just about you and your nonsense the
world and other life does not exist for
you only when you are playful you can
pay attention to everything you can
truly respond to everything in the world
only if you're playful otherwise you
cannot just the burden of it will kill
you of all the people that I profile on
my channel sadguru is probably the one
that I had the most difficult time fully
getting the message which is why I keep
bringing them back on and hopefully it
stretches me and stretches you guys as
well
this whole seriousness versus playful
thing I agree that it's important to be
playful
I think smiling is great I think having
a happy optimistic positive way of
thinking about things is really
important especially as entrepreneurs
because we have to deal with so much
crap it's so much pain so much misery so
much rejection so much other people's
negativity around us that if you are not
playful if you are not joyous then it's
really really hard to keep going on your
mission and its ultimate Lee why a lot
of people stop and they quit they get
consumed by the negativity and they have
to leave it and go off and do something
else that being said I also think
there's a time for seriousness I think
it can really help you I think it can
help focus you I think it can help Drive
you forward on your mission the way I
see playfulness the seriousness are two
sides of the same coin I think you need
both I think they're not opposite
I think they complement each other I see
it as the same thing as ambition and
gratitude I think you need to be really
ambitious I think it's important to have
big goals and set a life for yourself
that you want to go off and accomplish
and keep striving to do it and I think
it's important to be really grateful for
everything that you already do have you
are spoiled you are lucky you are so
fortunate just to be alive just to be
living in your country just be able to
watch these YouTube videos there's so
much that you have to be grateful for
that you don't even recognize and so I
think all of those serve each other I
think if you are just overly ambitious
and never are grateful I think it just
leads to a really dark place I think
it's never enough and it just becomes
all-consuming and I think if you're only
grateful all the time and have zero
ambition then that's a happy life but
you're not helping others you're not
serving others you're not fulfilling the
potential that you have inside yourself
and so I think of them as both being
necessary I think you need both of them
I think one stand alone doesn't help you
get to where you need to go and so I see
that as the same thing as playfulness
and seriousness I see them as two sides
of the same coin I think you need both
of them at different times to help you
go off and be that best version of
yourself and so that's where I stand on
it I'd love to hear from you guys I have
some special bonus clips lined up but
before that what do you think is it
playfulness is it seriousness is some
mixture of the two do you want to add
more context that might help me better
understand the message I would love to
hear from you please leave it down the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love enjoy the bonus clips and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events beso
let's pray so give me go
I've noticed that every idea that I've
had whether it was a drum kid or the
podcast or whatever it was past the
augstin they're all things that I felt
like would end up being really fun to do
and and so my kind of philosophy I'm
adopting now is like if it's fun fun
it's probably you know why that happens
it's a it's a bigger macro situation
because it's fun you're willing to work
your face off and working your face off
is actually the gateway it's not the fun
the fun is the doorway that gets you to
put in the work that gets you the
results because d-roc loves filming like
the 24/7 nature of what he does is you
know is why so many kids want to film
and do this but they don't want to it's
not fun enough for them you have to love
it so you're the cost of entry now is
you see you understand you have to love
like for me building brands whether it's
my own brand brands for the people other
things the why it's so the only thing I
give it about that I'm willing to put in
the 19 that it takes because the problem
is now with the internet like we were
just saying being the middleman and
everybody can play there's some kid in
Kansas City who's gonna put in the 19 to
take my now what's amazing as though the
biggest thing I didn't know is that's
some fun but there's so much that all
those little that are gonna put in the
19 are gonna get theirs too and that
makes me happy yeah
so I would say funs a great gateway to
fun is the precursor to ridiculous
amount of work which then gets you there
yeah right making TV should be fun
it should be a creative expression it
should be fun for me it should be
interesting for me and it should be fun
and interesting for the people who we
really talented creative people I work
with and that means the shooters the
editors the producers the sound mixers
the colorist everybody should be pushing
it and having a good day at work when
they come to work on this show otherwise
there's really no point there are many
many more dignified things in this world
to do than make television you should
have fun when you do it
[Music]
[Applause]
you know Lionel articulates this really
beautifully and it's a huge advocate of
having fun at work you're on these
things for two years do you really not
want to have fun on this is our lives
this is what we spend all of our time
doing so let's embrace it and have the
best time we can love young men
I haven't been home at all in seven
months one must create a family wherever
you can and that's what we did here just
to be part of guys gang to be surrounded
by good people hard-working people and
that's nice it's been nice you're formed
genuinely firm friendships would it cost
a lot of Kalitta by first and foremost
become really good friends and sort of
second to that is the creative
relationship that we have we were just
out in this gorgeous place and with each
other the whole time and ideas would
come up over dinner around the campfire
at night and we talked about a/c and
that's been an amazing lesson working
with guy and Lionel is that it also
seems to be that the best work comes out
the more fun you're having
lowers volume you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon they believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details